CHANGING BATTLEFIELD.E
RUSSIA'S MILITARY ADVANCE T AS
QUICK AS MOSCOW ANTICIPATED, BUT
THERE ARE SIGNS THINGS COULD
ESCALATE SOON.
A SENIOR U.S. DEFENSE OFFICIAL
TELLING CNN IT'S POSSIBLE
RUSSIANS COULD TAKE A MORE
AGGRESSIVE APPROACH IN THEIR
ATTEMPTS TO TAKE KYIV.
LET'S LOOK AT THE MAP.
YOU ARE LOOKING AT THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY.
44 MILLION PEOPLE.
THE SIZE OF TEXAS FROM A LAND
MASS.
LET'S LOOK AT HERE.
YOU SEE THE RED SHADED AREAS
WHERE THE RUSSIANS HAVE MADE
ADVANCES OVER THE PAST FIVE
DAYS.
TROOPS FROM BELARUS, TROOPS FROM
RUSSIA.
TAKING SOME LAND MOVING TOWARD
KYIV.
RUSSIANS S ARE NOW ABOUT 15 MIL
FROM KYIV.
TAKE SOMETHING LAND IN NORTHERN
UKRAINE INCLUDING IN BELGOROD IN
APPROACHING KHARKIV, BATTLES
HERE AS WELL.
AND FROM CRIMEA, ANNEXED BY
RUSSIA, SOME FORCES COMING IN,
SOME FROM THE SEA AS WELL TO
TAKE AREAS IN SOUTHERN UKRAINE
AND SLIGHT EXPANSION OF ALREADY
HELD AREAS BY PRO-RUSSIAN
SEPARATISTS IN THE DONBAS.
LET'S GET INSIGHTS FROM RETIRED
U.S. ARMY GENERAL JAMES "SPIDER"
MARKS.
AS THE GENERALS WOULD SAY, EVEN
THE BEST PLAN DOES NOT SURVIVE
FIRST CONTACT.
IF YOU ARE THE UKRAINIANS, AND
U.S. AND WESTERN OFFICIALS
PROVIDING THEM WITH ACTIONABLE
INTELLIGENCE, WHAT HAVE YOU
LEARNED IN THESE FIRST FIVE DAYS
THAT YOU SHOULD BE DOING NOW TO
SLOW WHAT WE KNOW IS -- I'M
GOING TO BRING UP THE
PICTURES -- THERE'S A RUSSIAN
CONVOY.
YOU SEE THE GRAINY PICTURES.
HUGE MILITARY CONVOY COMING
TOWARD KYIV.
WHAT SHOULD THEY LEARN THAT THEY
SHOULD BE APPLYING TODAY?
>> GREAT QUESTION, JOHN.
WHAT THE RUSSIANS HAVE CLEARLY
DEMONSTRATED IS THAT THEY TRIED
TO ACHIEVE SUCCESS IN FAR TOO
MANY PLACES.
SO IF YOU TRY TO WIN EVERYWHERE,
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO WIN
ANYWHERE.
SO THEY BROUGHT FORCES IN ACROSS
THE BORDER AS YOU DEMONSTRATED,
BOTH IN THE NORTH, FROM THE EAST
AND FROM THE SOUTH.
THEY HAVE NOT ENJOYED SUCCESS --
SUFFICIENT SUCCESS IN ANY ONE OF
THOSE LOCATIONS.
CLEARLY KYIV IS THE CENTER OF
GRAVITY.
THAT'S WHERE EVERYTHING HINGES
ON THE SUCCESS OF THE RUSSIAN
FORCES THERE AND THE SUCCESS OF
THE UKRAINIAN DEFENSE.
IF THEY CAN MAKE KYIV A DEADLY,
HARD FIGHT, UKRAINE IS GOING TO
ENJOY SOME GREAT SUCCESS GOING
FORWARD.
THE CHALLENGE ALWAYS IS, HOW
MUCH LONGER CAN THE UKRAINIAN
FORCES HOLD OUT?
AS YOU'VE DESCRIBED, CLEARLY THE
NUMBERS BELONG TO THE RUSSIANS,
THE PERSISTENCE AND THE WILL
WHICH HAS JUST BEEN PHENOMENAL
BELONGS TO UKRAINIANS.
AND WHAT YOU SEE WITH THE
RUSSIAN FORCES.
YOU CAN REALLY TAKE ADVANTAGE.
IF YOU CAN ISOLATE A RUSSIAN
FORCE, GET THEM TO END UP
FIGHTING WITHOUT SUPPORTING
FIGHTERS, EITHER LATERALLY FROM
AN AUDJASENT UNIT OR INVECT FIRE
COMING IN, THEY'VE DEMONSTRATED
THEY CAN TAKE THOSE FORCES ON IN
A VERY TACTICAL BATTLE.
THIS, HOWEVER, HAS VERY -- A
LARGE OPERATIONAL COMPONENT AND
A STRATEGIC IMPLICATION.
SO WIN AS MANY TACTICAL FIGHTS
AS YOU CAN.
THAT'S WHAT THE UKRAINIANS ARE
DEMONSTRATING AND NEED TO
CONTINUE TO DO.
>> FIRST FIVE DAYS HAVE NOT GONE
AS WELL AS YOU ANTICIPATED, IF
YOU'RE PUTIN.
THEY SHOW BELARUS IS ABOUT TO
ADD TROOPS TO THE FIGHT.
THEY RECENTLY TRAINED WITH
RUSSIAN FORCES TO WORK ON
COMMAND AND CONTROL,
COMMUNICATIONS OPERATIONS.
FROM PUTIN'S PERSPECTIVE, YOU
COULD SAY THINGS HAVEN'T GONE
THAT WELL.
LET'S NEGOTIATE.
OR YOU COULD SAY, I'M BACKED
INTO A CORNER.
I'M GOING TO LASH OUT.
THAT'S WHAT U.S. DEFENSE
OFFICIALS FEAR.
THAT THIS WILL ACCELERATE.
WHAT WOULD YOU BE WATCHING FOR
FROM THE WHAT YOU ANTICIPATE
RUSSIA WOULD DO NEXT?
>> WELL, WE SEE TWO THINGS.
RIGHT?
TO YOUR FIRST POINT, I DON'T
THINK DIPLOMACY IS REALLY A
LEGITIMATE AVENUE THAT PUTIN
WANTS TO GO DOWN.
EVEN THOUGH THERE WAS THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THE
NEGOTIATIONS IN BELARUS WITH A
DELEGATION FROM UKRAINE AND A
DELEGATION FROM RUSSIA.
I THINK THAT'S SIMPLY A HEAD
FAKE.
THAT'S OFF TO THE SIDE.
WE'LL SEE WHAT COMES OUT OF
THAT.
BUT CLEARLY WHAT THE RUSSIANS
ARE DOING IS THEY'RE INCREASING
THEIR PRESENCE WITH BELARUSIAN
FORCES COMING DOWN INTO THE
FIGHT.
AS YOU INDICATED, THOSE FORCES
ARE FRESH AND THEY'VE ALSO BEEN
IN TRAINING EXERCISES WITH THE
RUSSIANS OVER THE COURSE OF THE
LAST COUPLE OF WEEKS.
THAT MEANS THAT THEY'RE COMING
INTO THE FIGHT AND THEY'LL COME
IN, PROBABLY AS YOU JUST DREW
THERE, JOHN, FROM THE WEST SIDE.
THEY DON'T WANT TO TRY TO
SEPARATE THE FORCES WITH THE
DNIEPER RIVER.
THE BELARUSIANS WILL COME IN,
TRY TO REINFORCE THE AIR HEAD
OUTSIDE OF KYIV TO THE NORTH AND
WEST AND START TO BRING FORCES
INTO KYIV.
WHEN THEY GET INTO KYIV, THAT
BECOMES VERY, VERY TOUGH
FIGHTING AS YOU KNOW.
STARTS TO SUCK UP MANPOWER WHEN
YOU GET INTO AN URBAN TERRAIN.
SO THAT'S NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER TWO IS, PUTIN ALSO HAS TO
CONTINUE TO PRODUCE THIS
DISINFORMATION FOR HIS
POPULATION BACK HOME THAT SAYS
EVERYTHING IS FINE.
WE'RE DOING GREAT.
AND THE UKRAINIANS ARE NOT
EQUATING THEMSELVES AS MUCH AS
YOU'D WANT OR THINK.
>> LASTLY, I'M GOING TO BRING UP
A MAP THAT SHOWS NATO MEMBERS
AROUND RUSSIA AND AROUND
UKRAINE.
OBVIOUSLY PRESIDENT BIDEN, NATO
COUNTRIES HAVE SAID NO NATO
TROOPS ON THE GROUND.
NO U.S. TROOPS ON THE GROUND BUT
MANY OF THEM ARE SUPPLYING RIGHT
NOW MILITARY EQUIPMENT TO
UKRAINE.
WE ALSO KNOW, OF COURSE, THE
BEST INTELLIGENCE IN THE WORLD
RIGHT HERE WATCHING WHAT THE
RUSSIANS ARE DOING.
WHAT IS HAPPENING RIGHT NOW IN
THE -- AT THE PENTAGON AND IN
NATO MILITARY HEADQUARTERS IN
TERMS OF GETTING THE UKRAINIANS
WHAT THEY NEED WITHOUT CROSSING
THE NO BOOTS ON THE GROUND LINE?
>> YEAH, THAT'S VERY, VERY
TOUGH.
NOW A-PLUS FOR THE UNITED STATES
AND NATO GETTING ON BOARD,
LITERALLY BREAKING SOME MUSCLE
MEMORY THAT THEY'VE HAD FOR
DECADES IN THAT THEY NOW ARE
ADVANCING MILITARY SALES,
MILITARY EQUIPMENT AND MOVING
THAT AS FAR EAST AS THEY CAN.
TWO THINGS.
ONE IS INTELLIGENCE.
THERE'S TREMENDOUS INTELLIGENCE
THAT I KNOW THE UNITED STATES IS
SHARING WITH ITS NATO PARTNERS.
EVEN AS A MATTER OF ROUTINE
UNDER NORMAL PROTOCOLS, BUT I'D
ANTICIPATE THEY'RE ALSO BREAKING
THOSE PROTOCOLS AND GIVING THE
PARTNERS THAT MUCH MORE
DELIBERATE AND DETAILED
INTELLIGENCE THAT THEY PROBABLY
HAVE NOT GIVEN THEM BEFORE.
AND THEN THE SECOND THING IS,
HOW DO YOU GET THAT EQUIPMENT,
THAT NEW KIT FROM STAGING AREAS,
PROBABLY IN POLAND AND ROMANIA,
INTO THE FIGHT?
THAT BECOMES VERY, VERY
DIFFICULT.
THAT HAS TO BE DONE BY UKRAINIAN
FORCES AND IN MANY CASES,
FIGHTING THEIR WAY THROUGH
RUSSIAN POSITIONS IN ORDER TO DO
A LINK-UP WITH THE EQUIPMENT AND
BRINGING IT BACK IN.
THERE'S A REAL PRACTICAL MATTER
HERE IN TERMS OF HOW THAT
SUPPORT